it looks it already looks
pretty weird yeah it's already really
weird names should you think someone or
not
similar to what what you're doing
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna tell your
character what to wear how to customize
your character what's going on around
here i just need to put my chain mail
somewhere
so pissed
where are we and what are we doing today
i don't know
we're out at a green luscious green park
the only green part of los angeles and
we managed to find it this is where we
shot uh diamonds are forever and where
we shot nightmare
they're like like laces they're like
they're like pixar character boots if
you want to ask me about the meaning of
life i could probably tell you
oh yeah yeah what's the meaning of life
then
[ __ ]
money over [ __ ]
here can i test out that bow to make
sure it still works you just want to
fire an arrow i just need to make sure
it works you should lubricate it so it's
just goes like
like right into the chainmail oh i got
my hand caught in there
it's okay we can still shoot like this
don't move there we go
nice skirt
would you make it out of metal
[Applause]
so
the reason we're dressed up all goofy
today is because
contrary you start out with just like a
normal shirt and pants and you
eventually move up to classier stuff
such as chain mail armor and like molten
armor and you know like meteorite armor
and crazy stuff like that media right
now but um
we don't have all that so i just put a
jacket on and some bracers
we're gonna try out this today this is
the uh dji phantom we got from
dronefly.com
just recently
it's really cool thanks taylor thanks
taylor it's really cool i can't wait to
uh try it out yeah i'll tell you guys
more about it once we fly it hopefully
we don't break it on our first shoe
basically imagine the eye is
the size of three of us stacked head to
toe
so
around there and obviously there's a
little gap between us and the eye as
well
so that's a dial in your cg goggles for
that
next shot
um
will be sam shoots
action and uh we want him to actually
shoot an arrow in the shot but he'll
just have the bow up like he just shot
he hits the eye the eye turns locks onto
him says oh no and it flies at him and
hits him okay so get cut that's good
acting
all right and rolling action
captured forever okay here on the back
side
that weird stuff you just saw us doing
there we're actually getting plates for
our arm for the swinging motion the
visual joke that happens here is just
the idea that we're moving like the
sprites do in other words it's just our
arm immediately jumps the ready position
the sword slices and then immediately
jumps right back teleports to the right
position whether it's a 3d modeled arm
or a just like a 2d cut out that we're
swinging around
joke honestly i think is just as funny
swing that sword
sword transition so we're back uh from
the park now we're at our place and
we're wrapping up some indoor shooting
for the amount of video game related
videos we make we don't actually have us
playing the games in our videos yeah
this is the first one we're like sitting
down playing games and making a story
out of it it's a game that is still
unfamiliar to a lot of people and you
know for people to understand all these
references and kind of jokes we're
making about the game not to mention the
whole style of it what it looks like we
really have to show people you know the
gameplay we're essentially trying to
introduce the game to a lot of people
but also make inside jokes about it at
the same time so it's a little tough
this is the end of the video like us on
twitter
follow us on facebook
like like us or like our channel on
youtube
all right this is the end of the video
like us on twitter no
[ __ ] all right this is the end of the
video follow us on facebook like our
youtube channel and subscribe to us on
twitter
i actually have nowhere to go
you